pascale why did it take you two years to
cast your two lead actors for on the
horizon it tooks around one year only
one year okay it's still it's because we
had people in France we had people and
the whole cast was divided because the
story is in part France and in part Salt
Lake City and mostly that's the thing
you have to when you have to deal with a
low budget scenario then you have a
certain bubble of actors that you can
get to otherwise you can pay them so
mostly all of them some time I knew them
from before and but for Casey for Alyssa
it was a long process just trying to
find for you Paul Alyssa to find someone
who got this badass I don't give a
attitude and that is naturally that it's
not forced you need to have like him
this is Casey you know Tyler is Casey
it's not something that you create it's
not something that you can fake and
because we had amazing actor who did
great for the audition but when you
think is she Alyssa it didn't work it
didn't have this kind of magical spark
and so when I found that you know Alyssa
it worked but it takes time to go
through because we have 50,000 people
who auditioned like who submitted their
stuff and we Edition at least 1000 2012
a lot of people and you can see so many
people that are horrible and you can see
some people that are amazing but they
don't fit and so for him it was the last
one we we had I went through every one
and I had another case you now that I'm
thinking about it it would have been
horrible
with the Alyssa that we had and so we
just pop out of nowhere and I talked to
his manager we talked on the phone it
was just easy to second but it takes two
it takes time to find people who look
like star who can have good chop and the
timing of the schedule and so it's all
of these you've talked about having the
it factor do you think people are kind
of made that way or like born that way
or do you think they can adopt that no
you have it or you don't
it's not something that you can create
its yeah you can be better actor you can
have more experience but that it that
makes you interesting right away
like first of all if you watch Tyler for
the first time you say oh you got
something in it drones you to the screen
it's you know it's it's him it's just
the aura the energy around you so yeah
you have it it's not something that
that's the thing that is so frustrating
is that when you watch actors who are
great and I had like three people was
auditioning my last tree for Alyssa they
were amazing acting wise but they didn't
have this magical that was Alyssa so
when I found her sandy it worked
it just she had maybe less experience
but everything who she was killed for
the acting shop for the rest because it
was just naturally for her so when it's
time to be angry it was real anger when
it's time him so when it's time to write
it was real running so so that's why I'm
saying you know when you firm you when
I'm casting someone they need to fit the
part right away you need to have this
hit factor but it needs to represent
that part naturally what do you think
about that Tyler in terms of the it
factor have you ever heard other people
refer to you as having that and what's
your take on that
I mean again I'm flattered I'm flattered
at the Association on whether or not it
can be manufactured that's a that's
interesting because actors are such
chameleons that maybe their own self is
this insecure sort of person but they
can really put off this air of this
charismatic like I don't care I don't
have to do I think in that vaunt
I mean I think that vine in that vein I
think I think you're right I do think at
some level it really comes down to what
it means to have it naturally like in
the sense that is it still natural if
it's manufactured I think it actually is
because I think that the idea that there
exists an actor or that Brad Pitt or
Johnny Depp or any of these these guys
walk around and and have no insecurities
and never have and have never have an
off day or never not charismatic or
never not good-looking I mean you have
to imagine that there are humans just
along with everybody else and so I mean
I yeah I think that some of it is is
inborn but I certainly think that you
know a lot of is based upon your
reaction to your own weaknesses and is
that something that used to come - or is
it something that you build upon and I
think it's those that have built upon
their weaknesses that have that it
factor because there's a certain sparkle
in their eye that says I know exactly
where my weak spots are but I have taken
steps to address that I think that's
where it comes from
you